everybody
passengers arriving in China clash with
police as they are forced to enter
mandatory quarantine even though that
requirement finally expires on Sunday
since China began dismantling its zero
covet policy last month a huge sudden
surge in infections has pushed some
hospitals and funeral homes to the Limit
but only three new deaths were logged
Monday in a population of 1.4 billion
there are some estimates that perhaps 20
percent of the Chinese population have
already been infected in this wave and
to say in that context there's only
three deaths it's just fantasy it's just
not true Canada has joined some Western
Nations implementing pre-departure
testing for travelers coming from China
on Tuesday at Beijing foreign Ministry
spokesperson said those restrictions are
purely political and unscientific
they're going to get their backs up
epidemiologist prabhija says rather than
restricting travelers Canada should just
focus on keeping track of the virus with
random testing of arriving Travelers and
expanding aircraft Wastewater analysis
to all Canadian airports it's bad
science and I think even worse politics
to have this kind of uh restriction on
or requirement of testing from for
travelers in China we know it didn't
work you know just in the past it's it
hasn't worked at all equally he says
Beijing needs to accept offers of
non-chinese vaccines and share all its
data on what's Happening inside China on
Tuesday the World Health Organization
met with Chinese officials in the hope
of getting more of that information
so after almost three years of the
pandemic
the world remains divided by a virus
that doesn't respect borders Redmond
Shannon Global News London